today i'm going to talk about
hippocrates who was the great
mathematician who came after pythagoras
some called him the loony mathematician
and i'll explain why today what i've
started with is a triangle abc and i've
echoed the triangle by producing point e
down here he knew
pythagoras theorem which says the square
on the hippopotamus
sorry the square and the hypotenuse
equals the sum of the squares on the
other two sides but he said
it's not just squares it's any similar
shape
on the hypotenuse of a right angle
triangle will equal the areas of the
shapes on the other two sides and i'm
going to prove that with curves or loons
so what he did he drew a circle like
that right
that curve plus that curve would equal
the same curve there if i did that and
put the curve there but i'm going to put
the curve the other side of that line
here and he said so that curved bit
there plus that curved bit there equals
this curve bit here but hang on he said
this curved bit plus that equals the
area of abc but if those two equal that
then those two plus that equals the area
of the triangle abc
so this curved bit which he called a
loon because it looks like a moon
or a piece of moon
is exactly the same area of the triangle
abc
what he discovered is the first
figure bounded purely by curves
that you could determine the exact area
of the first
and then
he went absolutely loony because he did
it again
so here we've got another one this is an
off-center right triangle right
so
we've got that
and now from here i'm going to draw
another one that's it and this one
that well this loon equals that triangle
and this loon equals that triangle in
area and it's absolutely beautiful isn't
it now if you really love loons then you
can really go mad by doing this
i'm going to draw quite a few of these
now and this time i'm going to draw a
complete circle
look at that and a complete circle here
and now a complete circle
here complete circle here
these are all based on the center points
of the lions aren't they yes this one
here i think is the last one
and now i've got a fascinating thing
because with this one here and this one
here can you see this loon here this big
sweeping loon here isn't that beautiful
because what you've got is a lovely
letter q a round bit with two tails and
what can i tell you about this lovely
thing the area of that equals that
triangle
the area of that
equals
that triangle
there
the area of that equals that triangle
there and the area of that equals that
triangle
there so if you take the four areas of
this q you get exactly the area of that
triangle
and it's so beautiful isn't it
in terms of the area of the sky
or equivalently in terms of the area
this guy because the
last two guys are have the same area
well if you remember
the pythagorean theorem this length is
the square root of two